firstly folks I'm sorry I haven't been
around for a couple of weeks I actually
had mono recovered in last week's video
was not cleared by the powers that be so
I'm sorry for that but it won't happen
again
here's this week's video we all remember
the tragedy of 9/11
but what if I were to tell you that the
tragedy doesn't stop there
September 11th it's an image that has
been burned into all of our minds one of
those things that you'll never forget I
remember after the attacks the unity
that overwhelmed the United States this
feeling of moving forward and creating
an even better America than the one our
enemies tried to destroy but if you were
to tell me that nine years after the
attack that Ground Zero would still look
like this
I wouldn't have believed you I mean look
at it it's a pit with all the public
funding and hundreds of government
employees working around the clock how
does it still look like a prawn
concentration camp now see the key word
here is public funding now see the
government is in control of rebuilding
World Trade Center towers one in two as
a matter of fact at least 19 different
government agencies have had a hand in
this whole project starting to make
sense
see after 9/11 I like most Americans
felt that we should rebuild the Twin
Towers maybe even toss in a couple of
extra stories for good measure
not only would it show America's
fortitude as a nation but it would act
as a proverbial concrete middle finger a
beacon of light for all the Islamic
terror ridden world to see that's just
me folks
see instead former governor of New York
George Pataki decided to host several
years of design competitions which
ultimately didn't matter as he overrode
his advisors decisions in 2003 when he
awarded the task to architect Daniel
Libeskind who prior to designing the
world's tallest buildings had no
skyscraper experience and actually had
never designed anything beyond a few
stories leap said how do you feel about
designing the New World Trade Center uh
I've never actually designed any
skyscrapers that's that's why I'm sure
they're great can you have the next
couple years maybe never mind I'll give
you ten you drive a hard bargain Lipson
I like that it didn't really matter
because even after years of massaging
and tweaking Daniels plans New York
ended up going with an entirely
different design by David child no
matter it only set us back a few years
in government time that's like a
commercial break of course much more
feasible blueprint such as the Twin
Towers - proposed by the more
experienced Justin Berzon did enjoy more
support from the American public but
weren't really sexy enough to build I
mean who wants the same old towers so
after there's been around 20 billion
dollars sent to rebuild lower Manhattan
from the feds ground zero still looks
like this
all right very good now you're gonna
take them back what Big Mac I should
come over here
that's right now you're gonna take them
back woman take them I just took them
over here for you for you I took them
over here you know what you got a big
mouth you know that you got a big mouth
I take them over here you told me to
take them overnight want to take them
back gonna take them back here all right
all right I'll take him back here I'm
taking it back
okay ona do you want little guy now I'm
gonna go get it I'm gonna take it back
here gotta learn karate MA and even
worse it looked like the government was
going to dump the project on the private
sector I know how could they even think
of passing something of this magnitude
off to some greedy corporate fat cat
he looks Shady don't they know that
corporations and CEOs ruin everything
they touch with their greedy grubby
hands enter World Trade Center tower
seven
that that's tower seven well I'm sure
the bastard who built it did so at the
expense of others and Exploited both the
working man and citizens of New York
right huh actually it seems that Larry
Silverstein the man in charge of
building Tower seven actually pays ten
million dollars a month in rent on top
of his 560 million dollar down payment
and actually looks like he employs an
entire staff of people and is now fully
operational building these evil
corporate fat cats look at this hellhole
ridiculous to be ashamed of themselves
truly ridiculous but still former
Governor Pataki the New York Times
vilified mr. Schill we're seen as greedy
and unpatriotic because folks patriotism
should really look like this or maybe
true patriotism looks like the Deutsche
Bank building see this building was
damaged after 9/11 though not destroyed
and as part of rebuilding the state has
decided that they need to tear it down
but since they didn't really end up
repairing it or tearing it down they
decided to really just let it dilapidate
on its own and cover it with a target
then why fix it when you just put a tarp
up so the designs of a more privatized
Tower seven started in October 16th
really only a few weeks after the attack
and its groundbreaking was a following
May of 2002 and I know what some of you
are thinking well it's a nice building
but nowhere near the size of towers one
and two I mean those kind of buildings
take years even decades to build well
for a little insight on that we decided
to ask
Jerome Murdock a columnist for the
National Review about this whole
situation he gave us a few interesting
tidbits the Empire State Building went
up during the Great Depression and the
from when they broke ground until they
cut the ribbon on it was thirteen months
just over a year wait how long did it
take thirteen months just over a year
well there you have it folks World Trade
Center towers one and two shining
beacons of government efficiency
comparing those two versus tower 7 is a
clear-cut comparison of what the public
sector can do when compared to the
private sector now when you look at this
I ask you do you want the same
establishment in charge of auto
companies energy efficiency and most of
all your health care as always be sure
to let me know and I'm pretty sure you
can all guess where I lineup on this one
but what about the generic construction
worker what does he think what do I
think
Wow no no no you don't want to do this
cuz I can do this no no the whole song
no not on my channel no don't get to my
song